hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game it's from round eight of
the Kashima of memorial its former World
Chess Championship challenger Sevilla
carotene Carlson's old arrival and world
champion Magnus Carlsen brawling it out
it's again a very interesting game and
already two people in this tournament
tried to use World Chess Championship
preparation against Carlsen repeating
his games against Caruana and it will be
the same in this game Kerrigan also uses
the World Chess Championship preparation
that well now how are we said in the
comments why are they doing this against
cross and it's obvious that Carlson is
more prepared in these lines but you
know two people failed let's see how
Kirk in those with it and I'm sorry if
you hear some thunder and rain
unfortunately I do not control the
weather so very little I can do about
that but yeah without further ado let's
check out the game kirkin opens with E 4
we have C 5 the Sicilian defense as we
already mentioned the game will be
following the game calls and Carano vs.
calls and from there World Chess
Championship match C captures Knight
captures Knight to f6 and now Knight to
c3 and E 5 the Pelican Lasker variation
Knight d2 b 5 D 6 and now Knight to d5
everything the same I'm sure all of you
already know this line by heart he
captures on d5 Knight back to e7 and now
c4 we have Knight to g6 by Carlson and
now Queen to a4 and now we go into the
back and forth Bishop Queen maneuvering
we have Bishop to d7 not allowing any
nasty discoveries Queen before and now
Bishop to f5 caro-kann repeats Queen to
a4 Bishop back to b7 Queen to b4 and
Carlson also repeats special back to f5
and here kurakin does not want to repeat
it would be ashamed to waste the white
pieces with another Queen to a4 move so
here we have H for everything the same
as in the game Caruana versus Carlson
will h5 and here in game 12 in their
World Chess Championship match Cora
wanna play Bishop to e3 and also karana
tried Bishop to e3 in game 2 of the
rapid section of the World Chess
Championship match the one
across and one with the black pieces and
everyone was always wondering what would
happen if Bishop to g5 was played
instead then we had to go into that
supercomputer line that everyone was
talking about but here kurakin plays
Bishop to g5 and we go into the Queen b8
line the one that everyone was
discussing during the World Chess
Champion Jew match and there even was a
match between stock fish and Houdini
that continued the game from from the
position from this position Bishop g5
Queen b8 and here called a hurricane
started thinking and he spent more than
10 minutes on his next move
and he played Bishop to e2 so he
continued in the same way Houdini
continued this game against stockfish
obviously he is very well prepared
Carson replies a6 we have night back to
c3 and now across and finally can move
the Queen away from the last rank
allowing the rook to also be developed
Quinta c7 and now g3 are taking away the
f4 square from Carlson's g6 Knight
Bishop to e7 by Carlsen and now not
allowing the exchange but back to e3
controlling the b6 square with E 4 by
Carlsen a very nice move releasing
control of the d4 + f4 square but now
has control of d3 and f3 and now you
have this e 5 outpost for your night and
the night from if I've can come either
to d3 or f3 depending on what white
plays it's a well just a lot of activity
for black here we have castles by
kurakin castles by Carlsen and here you
can see that the h5 pawn is free for
grabs and this is a very very enjoyable
moment here you might think how to
continue this game do Castle queenside
you Castle kingside how do you what do
you do with the h5 point Carson just
gives it up and he actually starts a
very nice attack with with the time
gained from the loss of this pawn
correcting grabs it and here we have
Knight to e5 now controlling the d3 and
f3 squares and the now comes Bishop the
back to e2 controlling the d3 square and
Queen to d7 we have Queen to a4 now this
is by far the best idea that you do
you're up upon you want to get rid of
the Queen's as soon as possible you
don't want to allow any
tray
the LightSquared bishop queen might come
to h3 and already will have a lot of
problems so Queen to a4 and Carlson
declines the Queen trade of course he
controls more space he wants them as
many pieces on the board as possible we
have Queen back to c8 and now comes c5
your opponent is playing at the king
said you want to play on the Queen side
but here's how Carlson deals with it we
have D captures on c5 now Karekin wins
d4 pawn we have Knight captures on e4
and now C for removing the defense of
the Queen from the knight on e4 now the
threat of course is winning the night
and also the c4 pawn is a very nice pawn
you're preparing b5 which will cement
that c4 point where it is so tonight
goes back to c3 you can't allow black
the capture the night and the now comes
b5 attacking the Queen Queen to d1 and
having to go to the to the starting
Square and now even b4 so Carlson is
playing on King side and Queen side both
Knight to a4 not the greatest square for
the knight but you know you do you don't
want to put it back on the beginning
square not to be one
I didn't you're not gonna be able to
bring the rook into the game and well at
least at least I were threatening
something night to b6 would be a nice
idea and here Carlsen plays Bishop to e4
and it is from this moment that cousin
puts on his morphe head there you have
it and I am not joking this is a very
fierce attack so already you can see
that there are some dangers in the
position if you try something silly like
Knight b6 you want to win the exchange
or these six doesn't really matter just
Queen to h3 and white is already lost
the thread is Queen G - checkmate
and you can't really defend from this if
you try something like f3 you lose the
g3 pawn king h1 I'll get an IG 4 and the
thread is Queen to H - checkmate once
you defend you get Bishop captures here
just with the further control of the h2
square and whatever white place here you
just gonna play Queen captures King goes
here Knight captures on e3 controlling
f1 this is checkmate but it's only one
of the possible checkmates all
variations leap - checkmate if you allow
Queen to h3 so here kurakin finds a very
nice defense we have king queen - d what
d4 and now comes Queen to f5 defend
sorry defending the bishop
and we have f4 here forcing the knight
to move so how do you proceed here it
was at this moment where f4 was played
that says I showed that black should be
winning in this position but you know
it's it's not an easy position to to
deal with so feel free to pause this
video and try to find the the winning
idea for black as it is a winning idea
I'll give you a couple of seconds you
know take even a minute as you know it's
what's si recommends for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you have just played a move recommended
by a super computer and also played by
World Chess Champion
it is Queen to g6 you don't care about
what happens tonight because even the
night is captured Queen g3 is checkmate
the bishop is controlling all of these
Oh white squares along this diagonal and
the King has nowhere to go so the knight
will not be captured here kurakin played
Bishop to f2 just controlling the g3
pawn and now comes Knight to d3 you want
to go after the defender of the g3 pawn
h5 by kurakin pushing the Queen back we
have Queen back to f5 and the now
kurakin tries Bishop to g4 he wants to
give up his own light square bishop for
karlsen's a light square bishop so
Carlsen grabs it we have Queen captures
on e4 and now comes Bishop to d6 with
the threat Bishop captures here as the
Jeep on is pinned you will not be able
to capture back so Cara King goes Queen
back to g2 just you know
now if the pawn is captured of course
you will be able to capture back with G
pawn and we have rook 88 now Carlson
brings the rook into the game the rook
is coming to e2 and there is very little
you can do about this here bus up to d4
is played and cross and now doesn't rush
things you know as all all things that
are good you know they shouldn't be
rushed so first just grabbing that nice
pawn we have Queen captures on h5 and
now Queen to f3 car Akina again offers a
trade of Queens and Carson again goes
just
Queen g6 again creating this threat of
Bishop captures on a4 so you have to
either go back with the queen or the
move kurakin played is king - h1
just you know not allowing this pawn to
stay pinned and here cross the place
looked for a very nice idea the bishop
on d4 is undefended and also across and
uses this opportunity when the bishop is
moved to double up rooks along the
e-file
we have Bishop to f2 and in this
position cousin played rook F to e 8 and
believe it or not it was in this
position that Sergei catechin resigned
to the game why did he resign well if
you look at the position White has no
moves
really whatever white plays Black has a
black has a decisive attack we're gonna
show one such line you don't really have
a good move with the night if you play
your rook somewhere to d1 that that rook
really isn't doing anything you don't
you can't really move your bishop you
have to keep an eye on the g3 pawn the
Queen also I mean what are you gonna do
can play something like Queen g2 then
you get rook to eat you and now again
whatever you play you can't even bring
the rook into the game denied controls
that Square let's say you play anything
then black just creates a decisive
attack Queen h5 check with King g1
Knight captures an f2 grabbing the
bishop and after rook captures you will
just capture capture and now you storm
down with the rook and whatever white
does you can either give up the Queen or
move the Queen and now it's Queen h2
checkmate so just a very very impressive
attack by mr. morphe head Carlson he
doesn't require the head anymore so
there we have it and I mean look at this
position the 40 moves against a player
of Carrigan's caliber the the so called
Minister of Defence
it's just impressive but there it is the
third game someone in this tournament
attempted to play into Carson's World
Chess Championship preparation and
Coulson just you know Oh comes with
victorious so really I don't know may I
will see how with a Greinke chess
classic starts very soon so we'll see if
there were if they will be using the New
World Championship preparation against
Carson there but it should be very
interesting yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoy that we're gonna be
showing at least one more game from
round 8 so we're not going to be showing
the standings but spoiler alert
Olsen with one round to spare is the
winner of the Kashima of Memorial as
there's no chance for anyone else to
catch up to him there was a chance for
Kerrigan but not with him losing the
game cousin can just lose the the last
run and he will still be first this is
the fourth edition of chancre chest and
the cousin has won all four so very very
impressive feat by the world champion
and also I've heard news that there will
be a very short tournament short I mean
short because only three players Carlsen
Anand and the Dingley Rijn they will be
playing in a whiskey distillery and III
will tell you more in the next video but
seems very interesting you know they
should even include like maybe have a
shot of whiskey after a couple of moves
and then you know see who who is able to
reach the end game
I don't know ding is able to hold any
position but it's I don't know if he
could hold his liquor
you know I mean everybody that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Nuno Costa Mark Kotsay Raj
Kapoor Sheehan dammit Juarez and Harsha
try for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos serie think all for watching and
I will see you soon
like I said with perhaps another game
from from round 8 and continuing what we
usually do I think you all have an
excellent rest of your day and I will
see you soon